[Musique]
[Rires]
il est très très drôle mais tu as envie
comme il est pas si
tu places non ils disent pas
sa table non non
[Rires]
après mon chanson d'ouverture du Bye Bye
2020 et du Bye Bye 2021 là vous avez un
rôle principal dans le Bye Bye 2022
c'est quand même un rêve de petit gars
qui devient réalité ben maison c'est
vraiment un rêve en fait de toujours moi
je suis un fan de
comédie toutes ses formes en passant par
le sketch parce qu'il y a pas plus gros
tribune de sketch comique au Québec et
le Bye Bye je les ai pas mal tout vu
depuis que je me souviens
ouais une fois que c'est vraiment un
beau truc
chanter ma belle pierre il fait une
coupe d'addition à l'Olympia c'est
presque un ange pour jour j'ai assisté à
la première médiatique de votre premier
spectacle solo joke chapeau maman magie
piano et bien dit ça boum et à la fin je
vous ai vu j'étais quand même prêt j'ai
vu en larme qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
mais c'est vraiment l'aboutissement de
c'est pas juste deux ans de rodage ou de
c'est vraiment l'aboutissement de
d'une ville en guillemets je sais que
j'avais juste 27 à l'époque mais ça
reste que c'était mon rêve de toujours
de faire le humour de faire du stand-up
d'être sur scène d'avoir mon propre show
puis je m'en suis rendu compte à ce
moment-là que ça faisait toutes ces
années là que je concentrais toutes mes
énergies vers une affaire puis c'était
lancé cette chose-là en espérant que ce
soit bien reçu parce que j'en fais voir
de
toutes les personnages Pierre-Yves roi
des marins vraiment c'est l'expression
dans le visage vous êtes sortis de
l'École nationale de l'humour en 2017 ça
quel moment vous l'avez trouvé ce
personnage de complètement déjanté parce
que on a vraiment l'impression que votre
visage se transforme de Gaga mais c'est
gentil mais je m'en suis vraiment rendu
compte bah en fait j'ai toujours su que
j'aimais faire de l'humour physique je
pense
mais je l'exploitais pas tant que ça je
m'en suis comme rendu compte pendant la
pandémie il a fallu que j'arrête de
faire des choses pour me rendre compte
que
je suis vraiment je pouvais communiquer
des affaires même faire pousser des
jokes à un niveau supplémentaire juste
avec la face ou les mimiques c'est
vraiment un film c'est la pandémie les
chansonnettes le fait d'être obligé de
se filmer d'être seul avec soi-même
c'est
vous faites tout un cadeau pour la fin
de votre tournant 2023 le centre belle
chose qui est très énergique beaucoup on
utilise la scène au complet très rare
que la place ultime ou faire vivre ce
choix c'est au Centre Belge sur le plus
gros stade il y a pas plus rock que le
stage ça s'appelle Pierre-Yves a trouvé
la meilleure joke donc en fait la
meilleure joke était pas dans mon show
la meilleure chose est pas de moi la
meilleure jungle a été trouvé par hasard
par un scientifique il y a plusieurs
années qui en est mort de rire et puis
donc j'ai mis la main dessus puis je la
livre une fois une fois le 27 juillet
merci beaucoup merci à toi
[Musique]